[Music]
across the UK in every corner of the
country in our hospitals our high
streets and our households the
coronavirus crisis has altered our lives
in a way we could never have imagined
and probably forever
I've spent a lot of my career covering
Wars all over the world now I'm back in
Britain which is on a war footing and
facing the biggest threat to the nation
in generations
but in this battle against this pandemic
there is fear but also grit and guts and
a lot of humanity on Britain's homefront
[Music]
Warrington
a town equidistant from and overshadowed
by Liverpool and Manchester
it's bigger metropolitan neighbors in
northwest England the very unkind might
call it unremarkable in almost every way
except after nearly a fortnight in this
town we found some pretty remarkable
people doing a remarkable job
at the town's heart is a single district
hospital
the command center of the area's battle
against this global enemy it's the nerve
center of the community right now as
they fight a deadly disease we haven't
even heard of a few months ago but which
is pulling people together in a way we
couldn't imagine the managers morning
meeting they're constantly trying to
stay one step ahead of this disease
that means continually sourcing enough
PPE their personal protective equipment
they've never run out of PPE here they
believe their smallness helps but
they've come close the hospital's
intensive care unit has more than
doubled in size spilling over into
adjoining rooms these are those most
seriously ravaged by coronavirus
medical staff from all different
departments have been redeployed here to
the health frontline we're getting a
unique insight into the workings of this
hospital where the staff feel they're at
war and in this anteroom to ICU they're
getting their battle dress everyone
going into the high-risk areas including
our team is individually fitted for
masks to keep them safe they insist we
use their PPE we donate ours to the
hospital in return if the standard masks
don't fit then individually crafted ones
are ordered dr. mark Forrest heads up
the ICU the small hospital team realized
early on as the virus swept in from
China and across Europe that they needed
new tactics if they were going to win
this war
[Music]
patience the person at the moment that
you that's really exactly look like
about six to twelve weeks ago so that
that's this man fitting well that's when
the math first presented with his go
with the ammonia and now after we've
treated him and he's been ventilated and
he started to recover and this is the
one today where you can see although
there's still lots of like shadowing
it's nowhere near as dense as it is on
this you can see now we're getting back
some of the greatest the blackness
within the issue which is more aeration
of the tissues and so it's still far
from normal but that that pictured the
now man is now off the ventilator the
mortality rates of Kovac patients Horton
ventilators is shockingly high most
don't leave here it's a traumatic
invasive treatment inserting a tube into
the lungs under general anaesthetic with
the ventilator doing the breathing but
the patient still needs a very high
level of care the ventilator often leads
to the build-up of fluids in the lungs
that then needs to be continually
removed they're getting quite a lot of
thick sticky secretions especially a few
days part of into being ventilated and
anything a lot of encouragement to move
that that's occasionally the longer
patients on ventilation the greater the
chances of side effects as well as the
loss of muscle mass and the doctors are
finding kovat patients are just not
responding quickly we feel bad we offer
your patients that are sort of stuck
that that is still needed seventy
percent oxygen sixty seventy percent
every day they go for a little bit they
could have a little bit to go put this
stuff but not really gets you better and
we always think you have to be getting
better all the time
well think of it as a suggestion and I
don't know if it's true that this early
seems to be a suggestion you should give
people at least
weeks of ventilation you can't give up
up people too early you should at least
see it through its course
the team here realized keeping patients
off ventilators had a much higher chance
of success we meet Donna in the same ICU
but not ventilated she's awake and able
to talk hi Donna
sorry to see you in this position how
you getting on you didn't go on a
ventilator you must be worried about
that prospect why didn't you want to go
on a ventilator
[Music]
she came here three days earlier on her
birthday and she's desperate to live
she's made astonishing progress because
of this a black box normally used at
home for sleep disorders these have been
modified by the medics with oxygen added
and a sophisticated mask fitted but it's
pumping air in in medical terminology a
CPAP machine the basic we've got to
because they're meant to be only used
for kind of a 12-hour stint so we swap
them between 12-hour shifts just to make
sure that that she's okay
it simply gives peep so it gives that
end when the patient breathes out it
basically helps to keep their Airways
open the hospital only has a handful of
expensive CPAP sand there's been a
global demand for them so the medics
modified all the spare black boxes they
had in store from the sleep disorder
clinic and in one sweep the number of
patients they could help with their
modified sea pups
went up by nearly six hundred percent
everyone in ICU is hovering between life
and death and coronavirus is savage and
sudden in its attack most are frightened
the role of the nurse is critical and
Caroline's come out of retirement to
help those on ventilators are usually
heavily sedated they're often in ICU
longer or they don't make it at all
their nurse is a pivotal figure she's
giving constant reassurances with a
touch sometimes with a look always by
the bedside whatever conscious level a
patient has there's always the last
element the devil leaves a patient is
there their ability to heal it obviously
this patient you know is a little bit no
conscience a lot of patients I know
Carla so what I would she couldn't even
make herself known no no what to me she
looked so she wanted to get out of bed
and you know she's a very determined
woman and she wants to go home who wants
to be with her daughter and her family
and so I was just reassuring her that
you know she would get there and I I
think she probably will but she should
just have to be paid
[Music]
when we rejoin mark he's working on
another patients lungs which are filling
up he is however convinced their
approach here using their modified black
boxes have made the difference at
Warrington I think from our point of
view it kept people off ventilators so
it's undoubtedly made a significant
difference to us how many we've actually
saved with it how many we if there's a
lot of patients going back to the ward
that haven't needed Ceresco they thought
so it's significant it's a significant
difference we won't know the true
numbers until we start to look at data
and everything afterwards and share it
with other units that have done similar
things
but no matter the effort no matter the
skill this disease is claiming its
victims and some they simply cannot save
Ali Crawford is the nurse in charge of
emergency care her team remember the
patient's they've lost by hanging a
rainbow dedicated to each one on a tree
in their ward other tough choices though
absolutely it's not an easy decision no
matter who what age and if you've got
another comorbidity or an illness that's
underlying that and your lungs aren't
working anyway it's it's going to be
really difficult and I think it's even
worse to prolong something that's being
able to all the talking anyway weeks
into this crisis there are tributes and
thank-yous for those on the coronavirus
front line but for NHS staff the
heartache of these difficult decisions
is hard to live with
[Music]
Britten's coronavirus deaths keep on
reaching new more shocking milestones
there can be few places left in the
country untouched by the finality of
this disease
these are sobering moments for all and
in Warrington the virus which appears
inescapable is also the binding glue for
the community while most of the UK is
largely at a standstill there's constant
work for those in the business of death
in one of Warrington's family-run
funeral companies it's nonstop so we're
doing 11 and 12 hour days here every day
and then we're still on call throughout
the night and this time last week out of
hours we were called out four times
everything's up in the air for everyone
isn't it what we just adapt and we get
on with it and were there for the
bereaved families when they need us
anyway it says and it has got a lot
harder rather than it all exhausted just
for the sheer number of hours in
funerals we're doing but it's a small
price to pay for what we do they have to
go to extreme lengths to protect
themselves with PPE they've bought
themselves and sourced themselves we
will be wedding opp
just so it doesn't frighten them because
it does look a bit scary you're wearing
a full-face mask so they need one face
you know try to and you look at your son
sometimes don't look and yet as if it's
over the top never they aren't following
any guidelines they decided this is what
they had to do long before anyone
thought about the risk to Undertaker's
there's fanatical cleanliness enforced
everywhere the bodies are sealed in
fridges which are constantly full in the
two fridges got a city for a disease and
how many are full at the moment we've
got six out of the eight spaces at the
moment the Rana got two available which
we always try and keep for tonight when
we're on call are you expecting that to
be filled again tonight
I fear it not be very surprised if we
don't bring at least one more diseased
thing once the bodies are loaded into
coffins those are sealed but still
nothing's taken for granted even the
outside is disinfected again and again
do you think these are all Co vyd
related deaths the viewing rooms are
full this was where families could once
say their final goodbyes but the virus
makes it too dangerous now there's two
coffins in this one ready for the next
the funeral directors job has changed
beyond recognition but they are
perfectly positioned to gauge the real
impact of this killer virus how much
more the covert deaths are than what the
official figure is from just from your
evidence at least double I would say
we're close to double to the hospital
numbers it has to be all we can only
speak for our area obviously what we're
seeing in care homes and in the
community but for us it'll be as many in
the community deaths as it is being
reported at Warrington General Hospital
at the moment and you find that shocking
I think I think we're both a bit shocked
at why these numbers haven't been added
to the total people are talking about it
now what we realised this three weeks
ago that this was this was happening and
we were telling our loved ones our
families that we can't even go and say
stay safe this this is worse than it's
being reported
this is their job their livelihood and
it's done with even more pride now the
service they offer is curtailed by
coronavirus but the same care is taken
and the same respect of the debt is
shown silence outside Warrington
hospital
remembering all those health workers who
haven't made it through this pandemic
they stand here knowing it could be any
of them and almost certainly everyone
here knows somebody a relative a friend
workmates who've been struck down by
kovat 19
it's a challenge for them all even Ally
with all her years of experience inside
the hospital in the emergency department
where Ali is lead nurse life and death
goes on she's permanently worried about
her team who are feeling very vulnerable
absolutely terrifying and it's the fear
of the unknown you're a nurse you're
leading your team but it's around about
you become a 24/7 counselor her
emergency department is divided into two
now the hot clinic where the kovat
patients go and the cold where all other
emergencies are treated as a mother of
two herself and a maternal figure to her
colleagues and she worries endlessly
about them being in the line of fire
completely worried sick worried sick
just like after the slaughter you feel
like you sending them in and you don't
know who's going to come back
heartbreakin and i looked through that
glass and a pinata through that glass
with such admiration there are a lot of
young nurses have just come back from
maternity leave and I look at them in
there for life fp3
their kids full PPE and I'm thinking all
the time I've got a baby at home they've
got a baby at home just nothing but
admiration for the team but the fear of
kovat is deterring those who still need
urgent help you said before you were a
bit worried about coming in mister
what was your scare just my love just
wait I think every one days yes sir the
hospital has set up its own team of
covert cops their security guards
usually employed patrolling the grounds
but now they're entrusted with keeping
patients safe and the virus separate
from the rest of the hospital they lock
down corridors barricade doors and
secure a route to take the covert
patient up to a coronavirus ward as
quickly as possible
how do your family feel about you doing
it they're very proud of me so I've got
little children so but in some jobs it's
hard to shield yourself against the
virus Julia is a midwife who thinks she
caught it at work and knows she's only
alive because of the love of strangers I
came in on Sunday and I'm really unwell
felt terrible I honestly didn't think
I'd be going home have they could brilli
didn't really brilliant so my children
are constantly up and I just can't
explain how it makes me feel every
person who walks away from these covert
wards is considered a success story
perhaps even more so when it's a fellow
health professional
[Music]
and Julia's only 32 a single mom
bringing up three young children on her
own and grateful for hugs she never
thought she'd have again he must have
missed them an awful lot so much she
left behind a letter in tribute to the
staff you saved her thank you so very
much from the bottom of my heart for
everything you have done for me from the
moment that I arrived onto the ward
I made my peace and said goodbye to my
children and then I came to you from the
second I arrived I have had nothing but
the best care you came as strangers and
I leave here as someone who will never
forget the Angels that saved her life
the coronavirus is leaving its scars
everywhere but creating bonds way beyond
the hospital
[Music]
[Music]
hidden away on a trading estate on the
outskirts of Warrington a small band of
people from the town's Sikh community
are busy breaking down barriers
[Music]
whilst most of the town sleeping they've
been awake since dawn conjuring up
hundreds and hundreds of free meals for
Warrington's hospital workers some have
relatives working at the hospital or
stationed around the country but others
have no connection with a hospital at
all apart from they too might need their
services sometime they just want to do
their bit to help nice than that
services are working really hard there
is being daylight to save other life so
this is our little effort but these
selfless acts of generosity with
donations from hundreds of sikhs are
building bridges in this community you
know my wife will be living here and
happens a long time we never seen them
around they feel like now we go for a
walk we meet other neighbors which we
never seen before many have suffered
discrimination in the past but
coronavirus is pulling people together
and setting a template of hope for the
future it's a fight at the moment DISA
fight and the biggest people who are
fighting a fight with the National
Health Service hence we've helped we
needed to do something to appreciate
what the other and if you don't serve
people when they are in need
there's no point serving em
great a great great way to live your
life they prey apart but together giving
thanks for the opportunity to help their
wider community in this period where
many including them feel threatened a
plumber who's put his business on hold
is lending his van for the meal
deliveries me the secrets of the
Hindukush say yes you know everyone is
helping everyone out and that's what
they should be doing anyway not just
because of the virus
everyone should be helping everyone on a
daily basis on the right many here
didn't even know the Sikh temple existed
they do now it's always scorching by the
time we get it there
he's not really killed down what she
does a lovely gives enchant
[Music]
from the fear and panic of a pandemic
fresh friendships have been forged and
lasting respect created you can come
anytime the Sikh temples been here you
know 20 years we've been here we we got
a lot of people come in there on Tuesday
for meal you know if we like the police
comes in now and then but even after the
krona please visit one day it's amazing
how you come and do jobs like this and
in the middle of all this despair you
always find really inspiring people it's
nice to put a smile on everyone's faces
and it's amazing food just likes
everyone upstairs
the coronavirus might stop many
activities but it can't hold back babies
[Music]
Charlotte's birthing plan had to be
entirely rewritten her father was by her
side at the birth
[Music]
he filmed this most intimate of family
moments for Charlotte's partner who
missed his son being born because he's
in a vulnerable category at higher risk
of catching the virus
he watched the birth live by video call
making do by comforting his new son over
the phone when I ask the questions at
the consultants appointments and I just
sort of expected them to be like yeah
it's fine you can come into theatres
it's really sterile but they obviously
pointed out that there was a lot of more
people in a in a theater environments
and the safest place for him was at home
so obviously having to go home and tell
him that he can't see the birth of his
baby
they were citrus there was sad and
distressing for all of us but it's just
something that you're gonna have to do a
tiny bundle born into a strange world at
the moment held ransom by a virus which
kills his first few years will be
dominated by Ovid 19 now home and
finally with his newborn son Richards
looking on the positive side obviously
because I wasn't married for just I have
to make the best of a bad situation I'm
just really thankful that they let me
video me be there by a video link
there's a much wider health impact of
coronavirus it has emptied waiting rooms
it's led to a slew of canceled
appointments and is deterring people
from seeing doctors
far fewer people are turning up for
life-saving treatment but Ernie burns
who's got cancer isn't one of them it's
going to take more than a deadly virus
to deter him from his treatment others
are not so brave though and are staying
away or putting off getting help
altogether but at 87 years old
Ernie's more concerned about being split
from his family
what are your worries generally about
coronavirus because we know that it
affects elderly people will more I know
that my wife and I doing everything that
we can to do our share of preventing the
spread of AIDS by isolating ourselves
but of course I miss my grams children
as well now a long long time miserably
before this thing struck me I used it
now to a restaurant like that for a
family meal that used to be highlights
every week most weeks I was able to
enjoy that sort of thing but not not
since this terrible thing has been
plaguing us this kind of iris thing it
I do hope we get solders in this country
me thousand thousands of people do just
like me miss the normal life life's been
put on hold for so many entire hospital
buildings normally packed with patients
or empty the staff are all battling
coronavirus non-essential treatments
being cancelled and Britain is left
wondering when and if life will ever be
the same
[Music]
the coronavirus crisis is global but it
is so very local to
in Wuhan Washington and Warrington we
all have the same fears and we're
dealing with the same dangers and even
when there's no safe place to run to
there are those who confound
[Music]
we went back to ICU to find Donna who
days earlier had told us through her
oxygen mask how she didn't want to be a
statistic
her condition astonishes us I'm feeling
so much better I'm so much happier you
know I'm getting there
let me smells coming back my taste is
coming back you're gonna be leaving
place at University President he's
absolutely amazing when I came in on
Monday I did not think I would believe
in here this way I really didn't so
scared because after me so well and
they've really done the best nothing's
been too much trouble they've explained
everything to him I and I'm just
thankful to each and every one of them
helping me to fight this and get me back
to my children my family cuz I miss my
boys so much good day one miss purbhani
so much I even miss work I didn't think
I'd ever say that but it would be nice
to get back to normal and normal life
you know her family was always important
but somehow her close call has made them
even more so
whilst were with her she's told she's
going in the next few minutes that's
such good news we'll have to get you
there now because we're expecting more
people you've done extremely well though
haven't you you'll be fine on the world
work absolutely fine so go rings
security now to lead the way okay well I
didn't expect that amazing yeah now it's
time for her to make way for others
fighting the same coronavirus battle
the bond between Cara and those who've
come so close to death is a shared one
and so is the sheer joy at leaving I see
you another step closer to being home
with her boys this is a 24-hour battle
and it doesn't stop no role or task is
unaffected success and this arena is
judged solely on survival but the
coronavirus is leaving deep wounds both
physical and emotional Harold was in ICU
just the day before his wife Christine
was fighting for her life at the same
time in a different part of the hospital
their reunion after such frightening
twin experiences is all the more
emotional
[Music]
tell me how you feeling Harold
physically and emotionally we get in
there a lot better than World War II
amendment yeah physically I'm dreamed I
don't think I believe in really yeah
how much say that bad just take it out
of you really takes out out of here and
I don't know just everything just goes
through he had the emotions we were both
so poor you couldn't look after each
other at home and then we could just
couldn't get downstairs to eat I have so
yeah it's been a bit of a roller coaster
[Music]
yeah together
but beneath the emotion and relief anger
is beginning to bubble I'm not really a
political tape person I'm not really
into politics but to do we're the
government you kept cutting and cutting
and cutting at the National House
service and then all of a sudden Lucinda
singing the praises and then this that
and the other if doesn't cut them so
much in the first place maybe they'd be
better prepared for this these are
glimmers of hope
each survivors journey so different in
detail yet reminiscent and sheer relief
[Applause]
a few days after we saw her leave
Hospital Julia's exhausted and Kath her
mother has moved in to help
yeah I found that I got if I do too much
really breathless and quite hacking
cough I'll just get ways of where I'm
exhausted and can't even get out of bed
she's also had critical help from a
network of neighbors who are sensing a
fundamental shift how important has the
community become or do you think it's a
lot more important and I think this will
change people's attitude that in the
same way that World War to change
people's attitude toward everybody else
the emotional trauma has been huge Julia
told her mum she was dying and made
final preparations whilst waiting for
the ambulance
she wrote three letters one for each of
her children what did you say me I
definitely know all of them you just
told them how much I love them how proud
I was of them how they've done amazing
things in their lives and I knew that
they'd continue to be amazing how they'd
helped me so much in their
I couldn't have ever asked for better
children and I've got one it just became
home and I never expected to Kath is
unaware of the letter she left behind
for the nurses and Julia reads it out
dear staff of a7 you stood over me like
guardian angels when my temperature
wouldn't settle and despite the masks
your kindness and love shown through
your eyes I hope your management can see
how you are taking broken frightened
people who have accepted that the time
is here and spinning that round to give
them a second chance a whole extra go at
life I know you're all frightened and
unsure of what is to come but the hope
you spread is some tough medicine and
your love for each other and for us as
patients is immeasurable thank you
forever
worst experience of my life for Julia
and those who love her the experience
has highlighted what's valuable when you
become any element of health worker be a
home carer
all the way up to the top managing the
hospital you do it because you love what
you do you don't ever go into a job like
that from the money or
the respect or anything like that you do
it because it's part of the awareness
instilled inside of you as a person
[Music]
[Music]
Donna's finally going home another
survivor all strangers but all enjoying
the same excitement at leaving and all
just a little bit stunned they've
somehow made it
[Music]
this pandemics plunged the entire world
into a crisis of different degrees
undoubtedly
but we're all enduring it one way or
another Warrington is like so many towns
and communities up and down Britain and
of course they're different they're
unique they've got their own
individuality but they're also all the
same everyday people in everyday
communities coping with some quite
extraordinary times and doing it with
incredible fortitude
[Music]
there's a new love affair with the NHS
the pipers in Warrington are a regular
feature outside the hospital now
enthusiastic appreciation for those
risking their lives inside
[Music]
it's replicated around Britain the
official talk is all military
terminology of foot soldiers frontlines
and the home front
but once the clapping stops as in any
war there'll be questions to those in
command about tactics propaganda and
collateral damage
[Music]
it takes nothing away from those
fighting this disease but the survivors
you've heard from are those who lived
the questions later
might center around how many more could
have been saved
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you